so at the Jurassic world events in
Universal Studios I had the opportunity
to speak with two developers of Jurassic
world and if you're already familiar
with some of the other games y-fronts
here you might know them and we've got
Michael Brooks the executive producer of
elite and Andy Fletcher the designer on
planet coaster and they've both been
pulled away from those projects to work
on Jurassic world and it's been amazing
to be able to interview these guys but
to be honest I didn't actually know that
I would interview them until one minutes
before the interview happened so excuse
my poor planning and presentation but
hopefully I've still been able to get a
somewhat interesting interview out of
this and be able to answer some
questions that some people might have so
without further ado let's get into the
interview hi everyone I've gotten the
opportunity to have an interview here in
the stage about Jurassic world evolution
with two of the team and we've got
Michael Brooks and Andy Fletcher would
you like to introduce yourself so hi I'm
Director and drastic world evolution so
what are you guys like what is your role
on the team so my role is I basically
look after the sort of the overall
direction for the game and then I work
with Universal so the aging with their
back and throne with through halls and
through details I also work with our
sort of executive management so our
chief of creative officer level of
management and also work with the
disability for Andy and our production
teams to sort of decide what we're doing
from a design side we need my design
team we help to flesh out features that
we've agreed on the management early on
that
everyone's inside then as we move
forward we approach the site different
features make sure they're hitting the
right kind of marks and and then as the
game starts to come together make sure
it's balanced Metro is playing well and
yeah so I just did a let's play of the
game and I have about an hour where I
sat down on computer and played the game
along with one of the developers and I
like pretty much all my questions that I
had we're also doing their hour and I
like because of that I'm a bit poorly
prepared for this but you guys just
brought up a really good point about the
story of the game this is something
which I haven't seen so much in the game
yet so what is really the story behind
this game yes so I think one of the
things we wanted to do is we're taking
what is essentially a sandbox sort of
management sim we working with Jurassic
world you've got all these wonderful
stories all those sort of wonderful
events that so you wanted to make that
fit with Jurassic world in all we sense
so part of that was making sure we have
this narrative that stretches through
the center of inch into bats is dr. Ian
Malcolm from the very first element from
the new film coming out and we were
lucky enough to engage just for that
role and then we have the sort of the
three divisions that then kind of
provides sort of the meat story that
intertwines yeah that's right so the
more missions you undertake with the
divisions the more kind of character
based elements will come through and
depending on which which kind of branch
you take or it's where you go you kind
of get a couple of different elements of
the story or you can try and kind of
balance all three and try and experience
every bit of the story that there is so
yeah but the American character is
really nice yeah it's like it's
fantastic to have Jeff involved with the
project that he's no matter whether you
you know you go with the missions or not
or you want to sort of experience
tutorial he's there as a
the companion throughout the game right
you know your conscience as you go
through the island yeah because that's
one of the thing which I really like
about the original series is that he's
kind of the ironic communicator like he
always brings up the things which are
maybe bad about the things that the
characters in the film are taking almost
like he's kind of the conscience of the
writer get off the film so does he also
kind of have that roar in this game
Oh exactly that's precisely what he's
there for he's been there before he's
been chased by the t-rex he knows how
bad things can get and he quite clearly
thinks of what you're doing is a very
bad idea and isn't afraid to tell you
that yeah that's also one of the first
things that I thought about this game
because every Jurassic Park or world
film that you get it's always the same
thing it's a horrible idea to start a
pipe like this why are you doing this so
is there also a story like why the
player in this game is creating this to
ESIC worlds knowing that it's probably
going to get wrong at some point and so
we don't really explicitly state that
because we don't the player isn't
playing a specific character you've
never liked a role so basically they've
become a enter a circumstance where the
having foundation was sent to take over
their operations on these five islands
you can't leave that little opens to the
player can kind of fit themselves into
that mold right right and the player
does get I guess a lot of freedom in
what kind of park they're gonna build in
the end yeah absolutely I mean you know
there's no there's no store restrictions
as as Mike was saying you know we want
to maintain that feeling of it being a
sandbox you know for those players who
just want to play it their own way but
there's a lot of kind of unlocked
structures and narrative devices in
there that kind of tempt you into
different creatures of the game
but if I if I only like the herbivores
then I can put my park just full of them
and not have to worry about it yeah
absolutely I mean there are mechanisms
to say well you might want more variety
to make your guests more you know bring
more guests into your park but
absolutely you can you can just create
herbivores so I would want that
herbivores only isn't let's say the
safest they if they get out after their
enclosures well basically any dinosaur
and drastic world evolution is lethal to
the guests
yeah that makes a lot of sense one of
the things one of the things which I
really wanted to look into when I got my
our plane again which this is only one
hour so it's really hard to do
everything that you want to do is try
got a dinosaur out of its enclosure and
see what kind of havoc its gonna wreak
on the guests so I was really hoping
that I was gonna kill some guests so I
never really got a like a preview of
what's gonna happen once things really
go bad so what kind of things might
happen if your dinosaurs break loose and
how do you have to like protect all the
guests and save your party well I mean
if you're if your dinosaurs do get out
he's probably already kind of suffering
something already like you know the
dinosaurs attacked because you've not
been after it or fences broken because
of a storm but the fallout from that is
that you know the carnivorous dinosaurs
might be hunting down your guests for
food even the herbivores can be running
around knocking guests down which is is
no good for you the island rating either
and now you want to make sure your
guests safe as possible and we've got
emergency shelters in the in the game so
these are really cool these are kind of
like position kind of safety places so
if you put them down and you set off the
alarm then anyone within a radius will
go towards that shelter and be safe in
there right you want to make sure that
these are kind of spaced out in your
island so that if you know you've got a
don't still break out in a certain area
that the shelters in that area set off
and then your your guests are protected
right and of course you've got your ACU
teams to tranquilize the dinosaur and
you can always jump in the helicopter
yourself and you can have that hero
moment we swooped in and
yeah and I put tranquilize it basically
and then you can put it somewhere safe
yeah I've had that experience myself I
was horribly bad so far at trying to
actually shoot the dinosaurs they went
everywhere so eventually I just kind of
let the game automatically do that so
it's really glad that you were able to
do that yeah and you could fish that
chunk rage that makes them more capable
as well all right so one of the other
things which I was wondering is about is
the scientific background of this and of
this game since the original film was I
think also critically very positively
received because it so much took into
account of the science of dinosaurs so
what's like the scientific fact check on
everything in this game well again as
you say with Jurassic Park being sort of
more closely aligned with the book the
original books by Michael crying they
had a lot of the current scientific
thinking and even some of the more sort
of core it's time for anything but
obviously that science has evolved so we
are addressing world games so we do
follow Jurassic world science however
what shown in the film is an entirety of
the process so we have the sort of the
preceding step of going out and getting
your fossil finds so that was a great
opportunity for us to say well these are
the dinosaurs where we want to have
these are the places where we were to do
it so we're over with possible we made
sure that we use in the correct dig
sites for the correct species now
occasionally there's a few dinosaurs
where there's even like a single tooth
found in one sort of solitary dig site
so sometimes you've had to merge them a
little bit but were really possible we
kept it as
yeah and also think the dinosaur
behaviour we're trying to kind of make
sure those are as accurate as possible
as well so you have territorial
dinosaurs who will you know fight
because it's in their nature you have
carnivorous hunting dinosaurs you've got
prey animals that they'll prey on and so
I think there's some a lot of like
accuracy there in terms of like
differences between how they actually
behave the social one is also on on some
of the dinosaurs are quite social so
they'll kind of meet up their starts or
know each other and that's conical it's
a very readable behavior one of the
things that was probably one of the more
sort of driving elements for the
behaviour is to make sure that by
looking at it you can kind of understand
it so if it's eating or something yes
maybe a satisfying man need both looking
at each other interacting yeah that's
that's one of the things which I thought
about the game is you don't get all the
information like you have a lot of
trivia but you don't really get
everything some things I think you'll
have to end up in the final game really
figuring out yourself like what kind of
dinosaurs can I place together what kind
of needs do they have is that going to
be like one of the one of the challenges
of the game trying to figure that to
yourself out
I know that I certainly used to just
great one enclosure just for just for
Speed sake but you know that's just in
the nightmare as soon as you get
Carnival yeah it's because all you soon
as you get beyond a certain amount
dinosaurs because you find that they
need more space and you know in their
get enough space they get stressed and
they want to break out I think that is
part of you know the learning process
yeah how you do it means you can also
end up with interesting combinations so
example might be that you want some
interesting closure so you put practice
or the big sauropods but you can put
Raptors in there as well because the
sauropods are too big for the Raptors to
deal with where you put I got mine this
or you know something else in there just
gonna take them both around so you can
end up with these interesting some of
the interest species combinations but
yes some of them just need blocks of
space and don't like overcrowding yeah
yeah and AI is one of the most important
things of the dinosaurs like getting
their AI to be realistic and getting
some good behavior from them yeah
absolutely there's a really intricate
kind of behavior tree that they follow
so they have a whole load of priorities
that they kind of go okay any moment
they're checking what do I want to do
now is this to things that they can do
and they try to prioritize them as early
as they can so but there's also some
cool kind of reactive behaviors so if if
you just opened the gate near a dinosaur
and it will it'll pick up on that and it
might decide to bolt freedom you know
because yeah it's happened but if it's
starving hungry then it might still just
go so their head feeder feed right right
and this goes into enim every animal of
the game like i play some goats in my a
closure as well but the goats not in
escaping as soon as i was at least a
free-range yeah i ended up getting a lot
of goats in my enclosure this turns out
that if you don't have a dinosaur you
have to eat them
keep on coming they can't deactivate the
cedar so it stops them releasing so a
final question is one of the things
which you focused on the planet coaster
which is of course another game icon to
you is the guest AI and making sure that
that's as realistic as possible as there
also been a focus in this game well I
think it's interesting to contrast the
two because in some ways planet coaster
focused on like you say the guest
experience and everything was considered
from that perspective in this game
everything's considered from the
dinosaurs perspective you know that's
where that's where the focus is shifted
to they're the ones will open needs and
stats and you know the details about how
feeling feeling they are to the guests
the guests are still important you know
you still got to make sure they're happy
and they kept safe above all else but
there's a slight change of focus there
one of the really nice things we took
for that coaster though is some of the
expertise behind the crowd simulation
how they flow around so when you do have
a doughnut or escaping like there's
pretty spectacular things that can occur
they just big crowds just walking away
from ya the saw is it starts chasing
after I can't wait to see that that's
definitely something they're looking
forward to alright thank you for this
interview has been really cool to meet
and learn more about this games me
thank you
[Music]